all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
this one i got in many forms from a lot
of different people
how the hell did trump gain nearly 10
million votes since
2016 given the disaster of his
presidency
this is a really interesting one because
there's a couple of different angles to
it now
at the same time that there are people
on the left saying
how on earth would more people vote for
trump this time than last time
you have people on the right saying
clearly there was election fraud
because there's no way joe biden would
get so many more votes than trump had
in 2016. never mind more votes than
trump had in 2020. so
you do have people on both sides just
looking at the popular vote numbers and
saying this is
something about this doesn't make sense
the first thing before we even
talk about politics and and pandemic
economy all of these different things
it turns out that when it's easier to
vote
more people vote that's what we learned
undoubtedly in this election and when
you had
increased early voting and most
importantly allowing in just about every
state anybody who wants
an absentee ballot to get an absentee
ballot and to be able to vote by mail
because of the pandemic because of the
risk of catching coronavirus
where previously many states said if you
want an absentee ballot
it has to be one of these rules you
physically can't make it you're out of
the country you know whatever
we change that logically because of the
pandemic
to be much more open to whoever wants to
just
not go to the polls and it turns out
that
we were right all along the left was
right all along there is a desire
for more voting in the united states not
everybody not a 100 percent turnout
but if you make it easier for people to
vote more people vote
and that's not a particularly good thing
for the republican party but that's part
one so
both donald trump and joe biden got huge
amounts of votes
never before seen in any presidential
election then
the question becomes a political
question which is
given that trump had his 2016 base
and he screwed everything up i mean he
screwed up health care
pandemic response trade policy
immigration policy you know we could go
on and on all day
um how did he get more people to vote
for him
this time around and there's a couple of
different
things that that we have to account for
no one of these is the answer
number one the power of incumbency is a
real thing
when we say it's hard to knock off an
incumbent president
it's because it's very hard to knock off
an incumbent president when you are the
president and you're flying around in
air force one
and people are comparing a president to
a non-president
that will counteract a lot of the
reasons that if you were merely a
challenger people might not vote for you
this risk averse don't change horses
midstream
particularly for people who are not very
politically engaged it takes a lot more
to get people over the hump
to vote to remove the existing president
that's just
a reality and that's a part of it the
other thing
is there are people who wrote to me they
said you know one of the things that
happened
is almost inadvertently trump
land ran less and did less racist
stuff in the last six to 12 months
because of his focus
on the virus i don't know that that's
the case i mean
first of all from the china plague kung
flu
stuff um to corey booker
black senator will end the suburbs and
minorities are going to pour in and
end the suburbs as you know them i'll
stop low income housing
there were plenty of racist dog whistles
going on but
what is true is that there was less
hispanic related xenophobia maybe
you could make the case trump didn't run
as much on the wall
remember the 2016 campaign was launched
in 2015 on trump coming down the
escalator and saying
mexico's not sending their bests we're
going to stop
uh the rapists and all these people from
coming over
trump was less overtly about that
because he was very worried about
uh other types of xenophobia
and case in point trump did end up with
a larger share of the hispanic vote in
2020
than he did in 2016. so i think that
that's a factor
the other idea i have is
could the virus as as disastrous as
trump's handling was of the virus
could it have somehow in a backwards way
helped trump with minority voters
uh in that there are many
working-class folks including those
without college degrees this applies
both to white voters without college
degrees and minority voters but trump
already had the white voters without
college degrees
who saw hey this is a good economy
service sector
etc and it's being shut down and i see
trump fighting to open it is there
some way in which that resonated not
just with trump's
uneducated white base with the minority
voters without college degree maybe so
but again
it would all be merely by chance i think
that that's the important thing to keep
in mind
bottom line we have every reason to
believe that
this number of votes really was cast
donald trump
did get millions more votes than 2016.
joe biden got
millions more votes than that and
received more votes for president
than any candidate in history and we
will be analyzing those results and
thinking about them for much time to
come
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video